antonin edouard bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté de témoigner dans la matinale de
rtl france alors comment est ce que vous
avez vécu ce premier week-end de
confinement est ce que vous l'avez
finalement respectée à la lettre
j'étais un peu mal vécue parce que déjà
la peinture de ne pas sortir avec un
cours de 1 de 8 heures à 18 heures en
plus de ne pas pouvoir sortir le
week-end ou bien seulement une heure
dans la journée encore j'imagine que
vous avez moins de relations et et
pourtant c'est essentiel de voir les
amis quand on est étudiant
là vous êtes vous êtes seul à lens ou
vos parents sont ailleurs vous vivez
dans une chambre étudiants comment ça se
passe pour vous vous suivez vos cours à
distance
moi j'ai encore la chance je vais chez
mes parents
mais oui j'ai uniquement à distance de
ma chambre
c'était un peu plus difficile parce que
j'étais à leicester
un jeune que moi ont prié devant et au
cou
alors c'est quoi les conséquences
concrètes d'un confinement le week end a
notamment sur votre vie ça a quel impact
sur sur votre moral par exemple c'est
dur parce que tu voir les amis le week
end avec un peu à peu près où les stores
avant dans un parc post est maintenant
plus à parler les appels ou des messages
vous êtes étudiant en physique chimie en
première année pour vous ça s'est passé
comment cette rentrée finalement où vous
n'avez pas pu mettre les pieds à
l'université j'imagine beaucoup de
jeunes nous disent on n'a pas pu
finalement vivre toutes ces première
fois à cause du confinement c'est votre
sentiment
j'ai eu la chance en septembre de
commencer en présentiel mais rapidement
au pub on a dû
rependre le distante elle c'était assez
difficile au début d'année encore après
ça s'est dégradé de semaine en semaine
aujourd'hui je veux la limite du
décrochage comme beaucoup d'étudiants
aujourd'hui un acte à mondeville
l'ebit du décrochage c'est à dire que
vous avez vraiment le sentiment que
votre niveau baisse et le niveau en
général aussi de vos camarades baisse
avec ce fonctionnement la de travail à
distance pour le et des choses qui
semblaient être assez facile on n'est
que la moitié de la classe à l'avoir
validé dans la partie quand vous voyez
votre avenir en tenant à ce que vous
avez peur d'ailleurs pour votre avenir
comme beaucoup d'étudiants
justement je le vois pas d'état le
problème je ne sais pas ce que je vais
devenir ce que je devais faire je vois
pas plus loin que mon agent vite très
dur qu'est ce que vous vous dites avait
avec vos amis étudiants quand vous
communiquer avec eux ou par téléphone ou
alors quand vous pouvez les voir
éventuellement lors de vos sorties
qu'est ce que vous vous dites alors on
parle de ça justement par exemple j'ai
mon meilleur ami alexandre et en
médecine à lille et il dit que c'était
très dur il ya un euro de bourthes par
mois les 330 euros de loyer et plus 20
euros d'abonnement métro il lui reste en
50 euros pour vivre dans le mois hier il
me disait encore que lé aux banques
alimentaires pour nous et ça vous le
constater cette détresse chez vos amis
vous le constatez oui mais je la
constate je vois ça presque par tous
deux déjà dans les cours en ligne ou pas
beaucoup d'étudiantes dont je sois pas
là soient ne peuvent pas répondre
souvent très peu de personnes font le
court alors que on est essentielle
qu'est ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'elle allégements
pourraient être possible mise en place
par rapport à ce que vous vivez
finalement pour pour que vous puissiez
appréhender cette période d'une manière
peut-être un peu plus sereine
il a déjà déjà bien de revenir en cour
au moins un jour par semaine
la demande et la mitaine et aussi pour
les étudiants en gestion financière a
doublé le rsa aux moins de 25 ans je m
étais f devant 2 le clos jours de cours
en présentiel il a été acté par le
gouvernement c'est le cas donc vous
pouvez retourner à l'université un jour
par semaine pas non par exemple la
moelle de la mienne n'a pas les moyens
de perdre ta ça voudrait dire que
c'était il ya deux groupes certains il y
aurait un groupe à la maison est un
groupe à la fac et donc le l'épreuve
devrait faire pour en visio et pour en
présentiel en même temps l'époque où ce
type car il faudrait une caméra par ce
talent est là n'a pas les moyens de ça
ne marche pas est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être stigmatisés
entonnant avec cette crise sanitaire on
vous montre du doigt regarder à paris ce
qui s'est passé sur les quais de seine
est-ce que vous avez l'impression d'être
stigmatisés à tort bah oui de nous les
pas de calaisiens ont le leur sentiment
c'est pourquoi nous pas les parisiens
dans notre situation est assez similaire
ici
la population est beaucoup plus faible
on se demande pourquoi non merci
antonin et loire d'avoir accepté de
témoigner dans la matinale de rtl france
je rappelle vous êtes étudiant qui est
également secrétaire fédéral du
mouvement de la jeunesse communiste
français dans le nord pas de calais